nicolas bonjour c'est pas chaud ce matin
qu'est ce qu'elle cherche madame collin
du gris paul a aussi quelque chose
d'aussi la troisième vente que je rappe
ce matin j'étais complètement dévalisé
cette semaine j'ai plus rien par contre
j'ai un produit nouveau le ghana star
des petites gélules tricolore en bois
deux cents 200 g
personnellement je conseillerais plutôt
la boîte kg je prends ce moment à promo
sur une paire de lunettes de soleil avec
alors ça vous dit bonjour madame chez
4ad vous aider à vous non madame combien
les gamins ça ça vous tente pas c'est
bizarre en général vous prenez tout ce
que je vous propose c'est sûr
à bâle la semaine prochaine ça sera fini
la promotion veille surtout pour vous à
moi j'ai pharmacienne suivant épicière
non
or madame colère sans rancune bonjour
madame plantureuse installez vous avec
les autres c'est à vous et toi mon petit
gars dessin de la base qui motiva
naturelles abîmées
qu'est-ce-qui très plaisir tu sais pas
bonne entame un comité dessous 2 3 4 6 6
1 quand que de la petite monnaie
si j'avais par salle est petite pièce ma
c'est vrai que je suis pharmacienne
superficiaires bon des comprimés des
lutteurs que ça la mandarine temp à la
mandarine
c'est pour faire une blague à un copain
abadie le mon petit gars je parle de
winne attend voix
ces cinquante six à abattre tel cas si
forme ça lui fera gonfler la tête
servant de méchants ne veut pas que ça
se voit
tu pourrais faire part les cocottes
comme ça pendant huit jours avec le big
air max bon tu décides mon petit gars je
vais pas faire de la journée pour
exemple si saint-quentin abassis didier
siro sud rue c'est sucré tu lui en veine
fier de sa limonade et va transpirer
cinq jours de suite
oui bah en avant pour le sirop subdray
les fils quoi votre 40 centimes non mais
tu sais lire
y a pas écrit épicière bon allez saute
sur la passe que je veux dire combien tu
pèses normalement c'est 50 centimes
entre 25 et 30 kg je te dirais les
grands continuent d'avoir les 10
centimes revoir petit
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour excusez moi tout à fait à temps
il est 10 heures 5 et nous commençons
tout de suite autre vente choc
aujourd'hui je vous propose un joli lot
j'ai surtout pensé à vous mesdames dans
un sac plastique je fourre cissac domino
palace parfum nana 79 points au lieu de
115 calme et vous quel une boîte
familiale de sas en suppositoire
instinct gars il 35 francs au lieu de 40
une grosse pelletée de comprimés gélules
ampoules caché pilule divers et
multicolore en vrac 6 francs plus de 400
m de bandages divers bande tulle grave
en avant entre bandes à l'heure etc
neuf tube de pâma de parricide tout ça
dans un joli sac plastique vendus
sacrifier au prix incroyable de 175
francs allons-y dépêchons-nous je n'ai
pas que ça à faire
même à la plantureuse madame grandval
docteur choucas bravo donc encore une
belle freida mesdames et messieurs je
vous remercie au revoir
la plantureuse que si vous prendriez
comme ça vous étiez intéressé raison
excusez moi j'ai pas vu votre signe de
main l'avant si vous êtes intéressé
agité bien votre petit drapeau à croix
rouge merci